we're gonna begin with this the midterm
elections are just five days away and
counting leaders of both parties are
making an all-out push to win boats
President Trump holds an airport rally
in Columbia Missouri tonight four
Republican candidates he's visiting
several states that he won in 2016 where
close races could change the balance of
the Senate vice president Mike Pence
will campaign in Georgia where former
President Obama is headed tomorrow Oprah
Winfrey and Will Ferrell are also
campaigning there for Democrats mr.
Obama also visits Florida while former
Vice President Joe Biden campaigns today
in North Dakota President Trump is
painting a dark picture of the changes
he says will follow a Democratic victory
major Garrett covered last night's Trump
rally and joins us from Fort Myers
Florida
major good morning good morning
president Trump trotted out a couple of
new midterm one-liners last night saying
this election was a choice between
results or resistance greatness or
gridlock but the overwhelming message
delivered in this overwhelmingly
Republican Florida County Democrats want
bedlam at the border and only this
president the US military and oh by the
way a Republican Congress can save you
Republicans want strong borders no crime
no chaos and no caravans last night
President Trump again chose border
security as his outlet to draw a
contrast to Democrats who have
questioned the president's tough
immigration policies like separating
children from parents stopped at the
border some Democrats have also called
to abolish immigration and customs
enforcement a vote for Democrats is a
vote to liquidate America's borders the
president says the migrant caravans
weeks away from the border require a
military response one that mr. Trump
earlier in the day said could triple in
size will go up to anywhere between ten
and fifteen thousand defense secretary
james madison's will do practical
support based on the request from the
commissioner of customs a border police
and so we don't we don't
do stunts in this department on
birthright citizenship the president
said he's eager to eliminate
long-standing court protections for
children born in the US to undocumented
immigrants anyone who breaks into our
country and has a child the very next
moment that child would be made a
citizen for life federal courts have
ruled in Education cases that Fourteenth
Amendment protections do apply to such
children but the President believes
there's some ambiguity Congress has
never passed a law requiring birthright
citizenship for illegal aliens and the
Constitution does not I say that to the
media does not require it read it that
is the opinion of a comparatively small
number of legal scholars a far num
larger number of legal scholars sharply
disagree when the president suggested he
could end birthright citizenship was
simply an executive order and House
Speaker Paul Ryan disagreed and sharply
so well that prompted the president nor
yesterday on Twitter to say the Speaker
of the House quote knows nothing unquote
about birthright citizenship all right
major thank you